now I know that there's a lot of
skepticism about the vitamin D story
because of all the other studies
suggesting that vitamin A may be helpful
for example in lung cancer patients and
it turn out just to be the opposite
every tissue and cell in your body has a
vitamin D receptor it's been estimated
they're probably up to two thousand
genes one sixth of the Union janome may
be directly or indirectly regulated by
vitamin D we know vitamin D is
critically important for your from
health from birth until death we also
know vitamin D plays a critical role in
your immune function definitely plays a
part in reducing risk of infectious
diseases whether it will reduce risk of
heart attack and stroke and diabetes and
autoimmune diseases only time will tell
but I think that these upcoming clinical
trials are important but hopefully
things we've done wat clean carefully
because a lot of these trials are so
large the only way the participants are
going to be getting their vitamin D is
through the mail and more importantly
especially for the vital trial
participants are able to take up to 800
units of vitamin D a day even in placebo
group and so then the question will be
will you be seeing a significant
difference for those that we'd be taking
800 units of vitamin D a day along with
getting some sun exposure compared to a
group that's taking two thousand words a
day we need to look at them very
carefully before we make any conclusions
my recommendation is simple and that is
there is no downside to increasing your
vitamin D intake often recommend
children 1,000 units of vitamin D a day
adults to thousands of vitamin D a day I
personally take 3,000 units of vitamin D
a day along with sock separable sun
exposure and get a reasonable amount of
calcium from dietary source
you
so there's been a lot of studies on
5,000 studies in the past year alone
showing a relationship between vitamin D
levels and different aspects of health
everything from neurological diseases
cancer to to osteoporosis the fractures
Falls frailty vitamin D levels and
health outcomes are associated but we
don't know how and we don't know if
there's cause and effect well it's
interesting there really hasn't been a
lot of clinical trials particularly for
patient specific outcomes such as depth
or cardiovascular disease or heart
disease or neurological disease this is
a very large randomized problem 20,000
subjects conducted across the United
States and the outcomes are cancer and
to a smaller extent on fractures as well
as other potential outcomes but the
major thrust is does 2,000 units of
vitamin D have any impact on a disease
course in this case to develop cancer
alright and so this is the first time
they've undertaken such a large
randomized trial so we've met some of
the concerns from the previous small
trials it's large it's Asian specific
outcomes and it's it's designed for the
power with 20,000 subjects to show an
effect so it's controversial what is the
threshold for vitamin D but the
Institute of Medicine gave us some
guidance that 600 units of vitamin D a
day in the diet in out the individuals
on page 70 and 800 units a day and
individuals over age 70 is probably very
protective against skeletal
complications such as falls and
fractures some of that you can get from
sunlight but we generally recommend
dietary supplementation if possible
rather than ills and you can get that
from specific foods I think this is an
ongoing controversy it will continue to
go on as long as there are these
Association studies that are giving us
some bits of evidence
the conclusive data will come from the
randomized trial so we have to be
patient in white in the meantime taking
a little bit of vitamin D is certainly
not harmful and may be protected
you